[Applaudissements]
je pense
je suis derrière je n'entends pas ce
qu'il dit cheikh un traiteur derrière
ils savaient qu'un de 14
voilà le traiteur carte 17 heures est
toujours temps oui je né sais faire la
peau coup mais dis-moi choix d'ahmed
mais je commence ma dis bien aux césars
ge que je remette incessants avec des
césars meilleur espoir féminin on
m'avait dit oui elle a berné on m'a dit
j'adore et messieurs joseph américain
alors qu'ali calais pour une fois cette
chronique oil à faire tous les deux au
bas et pour les mariners que wayne bino
sur le plateau donc et c'est vrai que
camier mois on s'aimait s'est déchiré on
s'est battu on s'est cherché
surtout on a rigolé comme des ouvriers
et des années d'amour on a résumé en
images et camille je vais dire la vérité
quand on est arrivés sur s'est vite il y
avait eric dussart qui étaient avec nous
sur france 4
je me rappelle très très bien eric
dussart sur france 4 et j'avais été voir
le patron de cevital époque qui
s'appelait ara aprikian je t'ai dit
toute la vérité ou pas j'aime beaucoup
il est charmant la médaille je te dirai
la vérité ou pas ce n'est toute la terre
et ce soir on vous dit toute la vérité
de la vérité
j'étais allé le voir et je lui avais dit
eric dussart est très bon mais j'ai
repéré un garçon qui pour moi est la
star des stars c'est camille combal il
est sur w9
il fait un truc qui s'appelle asap et
j'aimerais le recruter et je m'en
rappelle car après qu'ils ont avec son
pif légendaire abedi nos gardes eric du
ca non mais il faut jure que c'est vrai
est ce qui est important dans la vie
c'est de jauger les faire changer d'avis
les gens exactement et il a eu
l'intelligence de me dire écoute tu as
raison je vais 10 sont jettés regarder
qui séduit les celui qui m'a vu non mais
apprend le et camille j'ai je vais le
dire franchement camille t'as vu on a
signé tout de suite
un arrangement avec moins d'heures non
il était dominateur des jachères
et il le méritait et c'est vrai que je
te le disais tout à l'heure tu as pas
fait une chronique pourri en simple tap
a fait un truc moi je suis là depuis 6
ans je viens tous les soirs je revois
tout le monde et je vois tout le monde
avec grand plaisir franchement m'étais
pmp comme pour tout le monde autour de
la table
franchement ces démissions corps à corps
a changé notre vie qui a changé ma vie
c'est grâce à cyril franchement on à moi
je faisais à peu près des trucs aussi
personnes les regarder vraiment et donc
voilà s'est réjoui nous partager se
chausser ses fans ses trucs dedans mais
c'est vrai est vraiment un grand merci à
bouleverser notre vie à tous les
spectateurs aussi
alors j'ai été heureux chaque soir on a
fait des années d'amour on a résumé en
images en amont sélection qu'il a versé
une petite larme jdas salle dequesnes
garder kamikaze comme un fou comment
baba bonchamp com
simplement série pour remercier encore
de cette magnifique semaine d'émission
comment vous allez lui c'est pas lui
madame passé j'ai surveillé the cover et
je me suis permis de juste noter les
quelques améliorations apportées
je mets le magnéto je crois qu'il va me
dire un truc genre c'est bien ça et où
j'ai envie de changer quelques trucs que
j'ai retenu à bon dieu
les affaires sont prêtes tu dégages cd
de richard cocciante les babouches
[Rires]
américains sarah c'est la raquette dans
mon coeur
j'annonce à moi en fait
les avocats ni lui délaissé non c'est
bon quand même mais c'est camille et
baba à chouchou et loulou
je suis où c'est vrai qu'on ait fait
camille et baba et dans un des épisodes
on recevait bertrand chamerois à oui
c'est vrai qu on a kiffé regarde
[Musique]
le média rives et lully c'était lattès
laguna fatah réuni meirav aucun
s'amasser fois la taille on navigue vers
trois dîners donc soyons réplique à ses
blagues à lui face à la jeune et ça y
est je suis un vieux con on va ça va
calme toi c'est ça tu a tout gagné je me
casse tu verras plus qu'un c'est vous
qui le verra encore parce qu était pas
bien ça moi on enrage le verger ça me
manque
pourquoi s'arrêter ça présente ses
bienfaits en refaire on l'a vendu aux
états unis
c'est l'erika m'a appris la mort j'ai
bien joué vous seriez pas non non agathe
pour dire c'était aux épisodes en quatre
minutes
c'est sûr que c'est vrai et vous n'avez
fait une chambre d'hôtel au mercure a
goûté on va pas se mentir on ya passé le
week-end on a passé le week-end on a
fait tous les épisodes ou frisé la scène
mais chaque fois vous êtes bien compris
merci mais on est très contents de vous
rapprocher de regarder comme un non
c'est vrai et aussi on rigolait aussi
bien l'antenne et on rigole aussi bien à
l'antenne toujours un béziers voilà que
sur les tournages de losc est le plus
gros fous rires ont lieu à las vegas et
les bêtisiers était presque plus drôle
que les sketches
est ce que tu te rappelles des formes
lentes et pour notre mariage fera plus
partie se marier avec cyril et en fait
on tournait pas on faisait que film et
sa salle mais tout le temps tout le
temps tout le temps mais voilà on
essayait de faire des sketchs je suis
pas prêt d'oublier son talisman tokyo
[Rires]
[Musique]
américano on va trop qu'il aurait dû les
bébés google potable telle enquête
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
c'est donc être assez basique
ah ben moi je pose remettez nous ça
passer en régie va tranquille google peu
tard et bien sûr non mais c'est vrai et
bien sûr qu amy tu as une séquence que
qui est arrivé il ya deux ans c'était
les frères me rappelle comment on s'en
était par l'élite et on semble
exactement et les normes pense quoi ton
frère je vous jure il en pense quoi ton
frère et je détestais petit train
d'ailleurs quoi sert la dîme et faut
changer crise mais c'est pas possible
c'est pourri moi c'est vrai et je les
gardais way et à tous les niveaux et
ajaccio maintenant il ya peu de gens qui
lisent et empocher motors a dit que ça
m'arrivait après j'ai tellement aimé tic
à chaque émission prenez camille je
voulais le décliner exactement soit
camille ils sont proches mois n'est pas
anodine
cette fois je voulais le déclic amis et
c'est vrai qu'ils en pensent quoi ton
frère on a on a fait une compil des
meilleurs c'est et je vous jure
quand je les fais georges les cantons ne
la parlent et camille jamais j'aurais
cru que ça allait être aussi drôle et tu
la fais vraiment mieux que ce que l'on
est vraiment élections et peut dire là
dessus c'est vraiment les gens ils sont
super gentils et vous savez il faut
faire signer les gens une fois qu'on a
créé une prison sans avoir
l'autorisation de passer je vous jure
quand on en a triché 0 en 3 ou 3 en deux
ans trois ans maintenant il ya peut-être
trois personnes qui ont refusé de signer
après le piège comme quoi c'est bon
esprit et ou parce qu'ils savent pas du
tout les gens 0 perdre trois personnes
maximum en deux ans on sourit et on les
a pas c'est quand même bien sûr
c'est parti
[Musique]
auger un scooter et je les prends quand
le scooter je peux pas le prendre quand
je peux pas prendre le vélo ça dépend du
métro ça faisait dépendre du temps et c6
et en heure de pointe c'est un peu
compliqué il ya toujours du monde et on
arrive transférant au boulot à part ça
c'est pas mal et votre elle en pense
quoi
j'ai pas de frère mais [ __ ] j'ai
oublié celui-là
les équipes des jumeaux dans pékin
express alors on est sur tout ce qui est
bon qu on cherche rotenberg la norme
allemande en avance sur les cures odom
enfin c'est quand même chaud quoi je
pensais que tu avais laissé je pensais
que j'avais réussi à me débarrasser de
mon pote et transports en commun qui me
fait marrer en en tout depuis deux
semaines gaza fait deux semaines que je
bouffe du ri pak huige et j'en peux plus
rendez-vous au totem au total huit
auteurs qu'est ce que vous pensez des
transports en commun sont à l'arrêt
transports en commun parisiens sont on
va dire bien parce qu'on peut on peut
voir paris mais dans l'ensemble j'ai
rien à dire c'est pas mal et l'occe
alors pourquoi la star pense non
[Rires]
[Musique]
aujourd'hui
la dass et les blondes mais les blancs
de carpentras vroon de carrefour
connaissez peut-être on en fait des
ravages au macumba
on a des choses qu'on fait des vraies
envies qu'est ce que vous pensez des
transports en commun parisiens ils ont
été meilleurs jeux suivis à paris trois
à cinq ans j'ai pris le métro les dix
doigts font à pied mais les transports
en commun y arriver et votre frein il en
pense quoi
j'ai parfois
on vient jouer
comment vas-tu toiles enchantées sortait
de prison là alors on sort hier
profitez-en vous n'êtes pas tarder à y
retourner
je pense qu'on a un bon choix entre les
transports beurre
les taxis g7 et c est le métro je pense
que le choix est large et votre heure
bon choix
après j'ai pas de faire une nouvelle
offre au pas tranquille le contre pied
de brice mais bon on s'en sort ça vas y
toi
parce qu'il a une surprise pour nous
mais c'est la façon dont ces faits c'est
à dire qu'il ya un camion qui est garé
juste à côté vous arrêter des gens il ya
quelqu'un qui dit à camille il est blond
il trouve les perruques il parle de son
phrasé aussi parce que quelquefois tu
adoptes le phrasé j'ai une fois que je
suis derrière j'essaie encore de la voix
et de manipuler on ça se fait en 5
minutes et c'est exceptionnel soit dans
celui qui arrête les gens et la renta et
les fabuleux et bien sûr abdoul qu'on a
vu aussi et toute l'équipe de camille
donc avis tu tribal de derrick travail
comme il est né d'eric je vais le dire
que tu atterris qui les dépasse que tu
étais candidats à la présidence à la
salsa français mais je suis passé à ça
de ma mère et vous le savez et vous
savez qui m'a donné l'idée
non et ben c'était le patron de la
chaîne mais non si c'était le patron de
la chaîne de l'époque c'est yannick
bolloré le patron de direct 8 qui m'a
dit tu devrais présenté à la à la
présidence de france télévisions donc
pour vous dire talent et qu'il voulait
se débarrasser de moi alors on peut
reparler dans un instant tu ça parce que
vous allez voir
bon bah oui plein de la plume qui ont
découlé que ça ça faisait partie de
l'histoire des 80 des pmp et tu avais
dit si j'étais patron de france télé mad
eric je serai plus le même et eric
serait peu un autre gars quoi serait une
autre façon serait beaucoup plus du sud
de l'allemagne
et donc la tenue tu nous afin d' eric
spécia la série spéciale alors c'est
derrick déjà il apprend qu'il est pas
vitaux 81 pmp ouais donc il a un petit
peu mauvais il a un petit peu la coupe
c'est pas des méthodes
et en plus de ça lui à la base
apparemment ils voulaient faire strike
le nouveau jeu est apparemment tu as
donné à la gaffe il était pas au courant
c'est un peu mon histoire de maxime
bézier
c'est qu'il a un peu la dairy qu'il
pensait faire une belle rentrée et
apparemment c'est la gaffe qui a tout
pris des risques en temps si vous
connaissez pas c'est qu'à me voilà une
formidable qui nous double d'eric comme
s'il était vraiment du sud de la tunisie
exactement tournant de l'onu demande à
tout le monde c'est parti nico mais
c'est quoi ce sera ce radio rythme et
nick setta nous naïm avait promis ce
trail qui le fil à la gare pour de bon
c'est sûrement mal entendu mon beau
d'eric je peux pas croire qu'il te fais
ce sens je te dis qu'il a pris c'était
quelques de la gaffe je comptais tu pour
me faire péter la nouvelle bmw j'ai plus
qu'à me jeter par la fenêtre et qui sait
ce sera qui grimpent aux fenêtres là
[Musique]
hier m'ont dit on part tout de suite à
6,8 pour leur montrer de quel bois de
chauffage sur ma vie y vont m'entendre
chez ces huit attend que je trouve le
plateau de strike tu te lèves et à l'asb
a revêtu péter kent au jeu tout est géré
à la baballe à près que c'est l'émission
atterri c'est au studio williams à midi
les animaux de la 8 en tête de la wii
voyage au bout de mon slip
mais c'est bien quand ici au voilà le
plateau de strike je vais te mettre se
veulent aller et regarde lui
eh bien peut voir la vie ça j'arrive ou
c qui se planquent la gare ouais
pourquoi faire ben tu vois je vais
prendre sa tête de jouer simple et je
vais lui enfoncer dans ce gros tarn
attac ont prié basique il est là
derrière vous vincent lagaf 2012 d'eric
commence à mon poulet alors qu'elle
augmente amène du bipe
najim québec je veux plutôt de temps tu
as compris masters j'ai toujours aimé à
la première belge grâce à toi au big
chill j'ai ouvert la vitrine je
n'oublierai jamais never fourguette la
east hier ce que vous venez de me faire
ça se fait pas tu le sais ça se paie pas
donc me prenez pas pour acquis j'appelle
hanouna fille ça tu lui dis le jeu c'est
pour dire i sinon le boulet je ne fais
que tes gars oui et bill je te le cardan
qui arrêta soukous cocopaq pas une
durite tu connais cyril beebip tu as là
il m'a filé le jeu
vous êtes des fins de série 1 écoute on
en parle ce soir tranquille pour les
huit ans de tpm p je sais que t'es pas
invité appelle mon pote guy roux il lui
reste une invit mais bible c'est nous
c'est derrick rose eric ça fait plaisir
quoi de neuf mois dix mois il fallait
être invités aux 81 pmp et qui a encore
une place et ce que je prétends
plusieurs aubin bien sûr j'ai vu ça va
être une soirée de fu yake libéraux béni
en plus elle est comme la cristalline
elle estime bob
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
merci
qu'est ce que c'est
elle peut